[Music]
and I'm Jenny right try to be in the
group for the day you know and you got
an eight-member
I can't wait for a performance on Sunday
it's gonna be we are so excited you guys
are on Entertainment Tonight we love you
guys so so much
we saw how excited you were when you
were here for the Billboard Awards how
excited are you now that you're gonna be
back for the American Music Awards you
guys look just like your fans your fans
do that when they see you I was at the
airport they were so excited you guys um
they all notice your hair change the
hair color you like it what was the what
inspired the change in your hair color I
did it for AMA yeah red color fight your
he said his color just got some darker
so he just did it again yeah it looks
good are you guys there's gonna be so
many people at the AMAs is there anyone
in particular you guys are excited to
see
oh I like Selena Gomez I was Selena
Gomez yeah amazing drag on okay dad
yeah Dinah Rose College Lady Gaga Gaga
the Queen right is Queen she's Queen
she's so good yeah um so how are you
guys feeling about your performance
um we saw this video that they got for
us like behind us and the it was amazing
the visual and the CG was amazing so
like you know all we could do is this I
think it's up to us so like going to it
you know as we always we're ready yeah
and you're the first Korean boy band to
perform on the AMAs I mean what does
that mean to you guys me like AMA is
like I'm gonna like we watch it the
videos in YouTube like we were like in
like 15 likes 13 so we cannot believe
that we have our first time ever us
televised debut on American award
American Music Awards so I mean like
it's gonna be I think a new opportunity
to reach out to the new fans and you
know like show them that our music and
performance is something that he can
relate to like even if it's in Korean or
because yeah it's amazing huh amazing
yeah it's great you guys really are
growing in popularity here in the United
States what was it like arriving in the
US and seeing all those fans waiting for
you at the airport right Wow right our
faith army I mean I love you that's
right yeah they want to know the UN
spends war know will you guys ever do a
album in English so um every our famous
already know but we're releasing our new
song mic drop remix with Steve Aoki and
designer and so like next week it's
gonna be something like English version
of something so I think we'll try some
some versions like that later that's
gonna be an amazing collaboration I'm
curious who else do you guys want to
work with who else are you dying to
collaborate with John goop can I guess
Justin Bieber Yeah right JB I am looked
you guys up
who doesn't love Justin Bieber huh but
no one that's a big one huh
anyone else Danny air CJ Danielle Caesar
okay gang go Caesar oh yeah you know him
amazing voice
Sabrina Claudio oh yeah of course migos
okay I love it
migos do you like hip-hop of course of
course it makes sense now makes Drake I
got it ha ha ha uh so when we talk to
you guys back in September our mu T's
that you guys have plans to come back to
the US for a world tour 2018 what can
you tell us about that um you know it's
you know it's it's sort of so for sure
we will visit I think more season
I think we'll definitely be like you
know like adding like more performance
and more status so I don't know like the
this particular time when we be coming
back but you know but it's definitely
gonna be like doper and it's gonna have
her yeah really happen there's fans all
over the world I want to know if you
guys are gonna be in their City I do
have plans for Europe tour or maybe in
Brazil as well all around the world okay
so we just finished our um this tour
like named wings and I think it's it's
gonna be there's gonna be like new
series for the tour so like of course
including United staes like like it'll
happen I think I hope that it will
happen everywhere every concert
absolutely yeah
they want it they were they were
tweeting the app asked me if they're in
this city this country this state so
everybody wants to see you guys you guys
are us you guys are on fire all right
you told us that your album love
yourself her was part of a new era right
so and you want your fans to learn to
love themselves and learn what true love
is so I'm gonna ask you guys what does
true love mean to you
real love real love Jonathan you're
angling for a car oh yeah chase through
a brother old and over Hills branch in
Java throng good good container probably
pen your oven drag a bunny Sunday
written gone through you have a mic on
if you want to translate oculus Ryan my
meal a we always like when we don't have
a like boy federal girlfriend we always
say like I'm so lowly I wanna I wanna
date you know sound like that but I
think I thought the biggest slow we are
such an is like the loved one was self
so I mean like if you want to love
others I think you should love once
maybe yourself or myself worse so I
think biggest love you know like the
ability to love ourselves
you guys have today you're so busy
money has to look at all the young
Karuna so horribly to do record book
tunes 90s introduce you
amen to that well said that was really
well said all right you guys before I
let you go I have some questions from
the fans we got thousands and thousands
of fans asking us to ask you a couple
questions so what's your what's your
favorite song right now like whatever
you list like clueless yeah we can be
like a BHEL yeah yeah cause like me and
Jill's favorite song okay perfect he's
good is it going um do you guys uh what
are you liking the food in America that
a lot of people don't know if you've
been to in and out like four years ago
okay
you got to come back first time yeah
where we just arrived at the airport and
then we had love that you guys are like
brothers is there a habit that gets on
your guys's nerves like what's thing
with one thing somebody does in this
group that you poke fun that
you always play games and but with
microphones so Wow I'm sharing my room
with him oh so he's loud it's better
noise but fine so I think we got a yeah
I better a part more something right or
headphones or yeah like yeah what do you
guys see the group and BTS in 10 years
[Laughter]
you'll be uncle BTS uncle okay we'll be
over that any plans for any solo
projects I know a lot of people want to
know about Jay hopes mixtape very beat
stuff right yeah okay coming soon wait a
meeting I can't wait to see what hair
color for your mixtape it'll be
different right yeah there will be like
a huge surprise Ravel yeah yeah I know
any plans for any other solo projects
okay he's got he's got his studio room
just got his new room yeah I've started
to produce some beads so maybe we can't
expect some alright alright we're
waiting we're ready I'm waiting - yeah
and finally if you guys could say
anything to your younger selves you know
when you were just starting the group
what would it be
please change your name what you did did
ya let's change her hair hahahaha way
them sunglasses in right stay hope you
everyday awesome
some not much has changed them huh yeah
ever say I love it
are my did why did you change your name
I thought you know that was um that came
from actually like song that I made from
like 2012 there was a some like phrase
like my monster and I just I thought it
was cool but you know as I grow up there
as I came to America I think it felt
like something like too much and yeah
you know like so like I just deviated so
I just could symbolize many things could
have more spectrums in it what does it
mean to you right now um I don't know
like real me or something yes see he's
older and wiser already uncle BTS oh
thank you guys so much we can't wait to
see you guys on Sunday